Цей будинок у Москві одна з кількох
будівель що постраждали від атаки
безпілотники варанов вранці 30 травня
внаслідок влучання дрона було зруйновано
фасад будинку та побувала шипки на
верхніх поверхах місцеві кажуть що чули
бавовну
десь вранці О 4 ранку пролунав просто
оглушливою силою удар дуже сильний більш
схоже на сильний удар грому дуже близько
Звичайно це буде ЗНО навіть хлопці які
це роблять вони ж прямим текстом сказали
що це буде і буде в кожному разі цей
безпілотник він летів не в цей будинок
швидше за все неймовірніше він летів у
центр або на Міністерство оборони або до
Кремля або ще кудись адже видно що він
потрапив у верхівку будівлі він просто
випадково вляпався
4:15-430
дуже сильний ударними вибух аж
підскочили з дружиною вікна виходять на
один та інший бік подивилися з одного
іншого боку нічого не видно Та й далі
спати
лягли рабочие которые робітники які
працювали вночі кажуть що приблизно у
четвертій ранку був удар такий що вони
Хто там відпочивав мало з ліжка не
попадали тобто був дуже гучний вибух
хлопок хлопок
як стверджують у Міноборони Росії Москву
атакували вісім безпілотників і начебто
5 Дронів були збиті у підмосков’ї ще три
нейтралізували засобами радіоелектронної
боротьби внаслідок чого вони цитата
втратили управління і відхилилися від
намічених цілей натомість російські
телеграм-канали пишуть що Москву
атакували понад два десятки Дронів 5 з
яких збили над елітним районом Рубльовка
у Кремлі заявили що Путін вирішив не
звертатися до Москвичів через атаку
безпілотників при цьому на Міноборони
Росії накинувся ватажок пвк Вагнер Євген
пригожин Який давно конфліктує з
міністром оборони РФ Сергієм Шойгу та
начальником генштабу РФ валерієм
герасимовим
по поводу безпілотніков которые летают
над Москвы и в Москве
тварі вонючи Вы что творите вы скоти
отрывайте свои [__] из кабинетов из
которых вас посадили защищать Эту страну
вы являетесь министерством обороны вы не
сделали ни [__] для того чтоб наступать
какого вы допускаете прилёта этих
беспилотников в Москву то есть они на
рублёвку летят к вам домой ты хрен ты с
ним Пускай ваши дома полыхают А что
людям обычным делать когда вы хохно
врезаются беспилодники со взрывчатым
веществом и в этом как гражданин як
луган глубоко возмущен Что эти мразье
спокойной сидят прости живуть дальше
твоя жеревшие [__] намазанные дракими
кремами
вопросы этим паскудам
в атаці безпілотників на Москву
Міноборони Росії звинуватили Україну в
офісі ж президенту України стверджують
що Київ немає прямого відношення до
атаки ми ж втягимся верви іскуственного
інтелекту ви знаєте ми ж втягуємося
велоштучного інтелекту можливо не всі
дрони готові атакувати Україну і хочуть
повернутися до своїх творців відповідним
чином поставити запитання А навіщо ви
нас відправляєте бити по дітях України
по бігу і так далі
Почему он должен бомбить Украину к
искусственно бути штучного інтелекту ми
маємо відношення а до атак Ну ми з
задоволенням дивимося і прогнозуємо
збільшення кількості атак Але звичайно
прямого відношення не маємо
на думку експертки із питань безпеки у
Лондонського кінг-коледжу зараз кожна
сторона конфлікту намагатиметься
пояснити те що сталося як найвигідніше
для себе
з одного боку це може бути операція Під
чужим прапором що означає що за атакою
безпілотників у такому разі швидше за
все стоять російські спецслужби це
зміцнило б наратив Росії та необхідність
продовження так званої спеціальної
військової операції з іншого боку ми
також чули заяву голови Української
військової розвідки буданова який каже
про відповідь України на нещодавні атаки
безпілотників на Київ це означає що
українська сторона також була б
зацікавлена показати що вона може
оминути російську протиповітряну оборону
та досягти серця Москви чи Кремля на
початку травня два дрони також атакували
Московський Кремль у Києві тоді також
відкинули звинувачення Москви і така
поведінка практично стандартна практика
з обох зазначає британський військовий
експерт Майк Мартін
і це сягає Того часу коли у Росії були
маленькі зелені чоловічки в Криму І вона
говорила що немає до них жодного
відношення а Україна впродовж усієї
війни коментуючи різні диверсійні місії
чи атаки фактично говорила о ми нічого
про це не знаємо
проте Атака Дронів швидше за все
свідчить про активізацію бойових дій
зазначає австрійський політолог професор
з міжнародних відносин в університеті
інсбрука гергард манго
українська сторона очевидно хоче
принести Жак війни і до столиці росіянам
хочуть дати зрозуміти що держава не
здатна захистити їх ні у прикордонних
регіонах ні у Москві і це підриває
амбіції Путіна а саме створити в
російському суспільстві враження що
жодної Війни немає що Все начебто
нормально
експерт звертає увагу що за словами
прес-секретаря земля Президент Росії
Володимир Путін не планує звертатися до
громадян країни у зв'язку з атакою
безпілотників на Москву хоча насправді
він міг би сказати населення дивіться
наскільки важлива боротьба з Україною
вона тероризує вас це вільне населення
але на думку Путіна Я думаю це ще гірше
транслювати щось подібне бо це зробила
очевидним що російська протиповітряна
оборона працює Погано І що держава не в
змозі захистити населення у Москві тому
він вважає за краще Мовчан
використання безпілотників має велике
значення у цій війні зазначають експерти
є для розвитку і завдання ударів по
цілях на землі які тип зброї був
використаний для удару по Москві
експертам поки що важко дати однозначну
відповідь
на цьому етапі дуже важко визначити
походження Дронів і я думаю що буде
багато туману коли Справа дійде туди
в ніч на вівторок сталося чергуватарка
безпілотників і на Україну за Ісусом
повідомляють про щонайменше 31 грунт І
мікадзе за даними українських військових
Над Києвом було збито 29 з них